thank you
[Music]
uh so are you guys familiar with the
film office space Oh yeah the red
stapler one have you seen my stapler so
that movie gave a guy working at a
company in Washington state a pretty
sick idea he's like Burn It Down
close steal a penny enough every
transaction yes oh he's like what if I
you know install this software that
siphons a very small amount of money
into my personal bank account this one a
little bit as they make transactions
yeah that's not too bad and he did
exactly that so uh can it go through its
personal bank account what an idiot he
he stole
um about 260 thousand dollars in
electric in electric payments and more
than forty thousand dollars in
merchandise from the business he did it
through the utilities how long did it
take he he did he did a um
so in the movie they call it a series of
malicious software edits
um and that's that's what he did he
installed this kind of software on his
company laptop and was just using it to
siphon money into his personal things
yeah wow what was the duration of time
it took for him to get that money
um it doesn't say is there a picture of
the guy in the rain yeah [ __ ] you
um yeah he's being arraigned um and um
exterior shot of the building
according to court documents he stole
110 000 by diverting shipping fees from
some customers to an account that he
controlled on the payment processing
site stripe and and after there was an
investigation about it he wrote a
replacement code that double charged
some customers for shipping and routed
an additional 151 000 in fees to his
stripe account
where people not [ __ ] calling out the
fact that they were paying double
shipping on stuff eventually eventually
that's how they found out about it but
he was also manipulating the prices of
merchandise sold on oh so it looked like
it wasn't double shipping it was like a
discount on the product or something
like that yes so he would per he would
purchase those remember I said how much
money he stole in merchandise yeah he
was purchasing those items for pennies
on the dollar paying like 250 dollars
for like something that's worth a lot
more money
um and he was getting away with it for a
certain amount of time sometimes I wish
I was that smart but then I'm glad I'm
not because I'd be in jail probably yeah
yeah these people got crazy like even
like the black box right you know when
we grew up for cable yeah it's like a
theme that like a dream you could just
you know just just just so happy to get
all the channels and then you just gotta
pay a random guy that has nothing to do
with any of the networks or the direct
or DirecTV dish just a contractor but
somehow they know how to do it and it
just and then you can watch everything
yeah it's already like all those Pro all
the shows are already going to your
house it's just that way you don't pay
to unlock it and someone knew how to
make something to unlock all the shows
dude there's people in crypto game who
um do this thing called Arbitrage where
it's like you find price disparities
between two exchanges say and then you
write code and have Bots constantly buy
and sell between those two things and
you can just rack up like on the margins
yeah thousands and thousands and
thousands of dollars and some people
just do that all day for a [ __ ]
living whoa
yes yeah that's definitely a goal that I
would like to have was figure out how to
do that you have to be sick but you just
need to like be dedicated to it
constantly
um okay so this guy when he got caught
right he's like well this is kind of
part of like a testing process
um I was just kind of seeing what would
happen oh he's trying to I think he's a
white hat yeah yeah yeah yeah funny and
he told the police that the money is
gone and then he invested in GameStop
no way yeah that's my favorite part
about this no way that's what he said
but it was gme but it was still a test
he was just testing it yeah but he had
to test the money too so does that mean
he he made money and was able to return
what he had stolen
the merchandise he didn't sell GameStop
he was a big time holder
he's a diamond
hands yeah he's like he's on Wall Street
bets talking about he's the biggest
diamond Handler alive yeah he's like I'm
white knuckling this thing like you you
take that money out right now he's like
how how do I do that yeah I'm not gonna
sell my stuff that is the trick that's
the what's the procedure for that yeah
Robin Hood would have let me take it out
FTX said no yeah they just said no he
said no in a funny scenario they would
be like interrogating this guy and he
tells him that he put it in GameStop and
then these interrogators leave the room
having bought game stuff that's funny as
[ __ ] in the office space in there like
yeah I should be checking out this Jimmy
honestly interested in Diamond handing
um
so
they discovered a pattern of steep price
adjustments that he ordered and had
shipped to his home as well as to a
female friend who he later identified as
someone he met on Tinder this guy is so
sick that it's insane right like he's
like I'll ship all this [ __ ] to my house
he's like oh ship it to this [ __ ] I'm
out it'll be sick and then it's all so
personal and obvious yeah like he's such
a smarty but then he's so [ __ ] dumb
at the same time his resources are so
stupid I could trust this girl on Tinder
and then he goes where is it at it's all
gone at least the McDonald's scammers
were like Doom like uh yeah
yeah they were using family but like
kind of like uncles and aunts and [ __ ]
that's a little less direct but this
Captain into his own home address
yeah yeah and he's like I don't know oh
I'll buy gme on Robinhood my personal
Robin Hood account have you guys ever
been like shortchanged before where like
you were kind of like scammed a little
bit like this I gotta well not like this
but I've been uh dealing with Chegg you
hear about that what's that Chegg it was
this old website that people would use
to like rent um textbooks from college
and I've been finding out they've been
[ __ ] charging my account 20 bucks
every [ __ ] month every month since
College I don't know since for the past
like two like for the past like year and
a half whoa how did that start fraud
someone [ __ ] and I called check I was
like yo I didn't I haven't used this
[ __ ] no for years
and then this guy was like he was like
from Brooklyn he was like the coolest
dude ever and he was like trying to
figure it out he's like yup it's fraud
he's like have you ever lived at this
address he said some address I've never
heard of in my life and I was like I've
never lived there and he goes all right
I'm a marketer's fraud you gotta talk to
your bank and then they're hopefully a
refund we'll figure it out blah blah
blah so now I gotta call the bank so
that company that Textbook Company are
they the fraudulent company I don't
think so no maybe someone in-house some
some guy just made probably a fake
account or something weird I got got
um when I I bought like I had to buy
apartment Insurance when I first moved
to LA like I was living in like the
Westwood Apartments remember that's like
oh the Oakwood the Hollywood all the
actors are always there and [ __ ] so I I
stayed there but then they made me get
this insurance and then I found out like
five years later that it's like Auto
building my account like 25 a month and
then I called this insurance company I
was like yo you guys would rip me off I
haven't been I haven't lived there for
like [ __ ] five years and the guy's
like what are you gonna do about it no
way yeah it's because it's part of their
business model it's different than that
cat where they probably take money
legitimately this guy's like what are
you gonna do I was like I think he has a
small claim score
bluffing and then he's like yeah okay I
guess I'll see you there
is he probably everyone's probably did
it yeah he can give a [ __ ] he's like I
know how to fight it check your
subscription
why are you doing that that's crazy
hearing that yeah but if the law doesn't
work sometimes you got to use fists not
recommending but just I don't know like
it's something that people say right I
don't know where this guy was though
because it was like one of those [ __ ]
weird things where he registered it as
something else you know what [ __ ]
gets me those goddamn Instagram plugins
and [ __ ]
you know sometimes like you get like Oh
I wanna I wanna repost or I want to like
you know have like some pictures like a
like a collage but the ones on Instagram
suck ass so you're like oh like apps
yeah apps you're like oh I gotta go get
an app and then you go okay I'll just
use it for one time it's 4.99 not a bad
thing and you just click it and then you
forget about it and then [ __ ] eight
months later they're like damn I've been
paying 4.99 for eight months [ __ ] yeah
for real and then he canceled it and you
cancel it okay good and then you're like
oh [ __ ] I need that
remember it now you're like oh dude that
app was pretty good but then you get
enough of those things it can add up
you're like you oh get the collage one
I'll get the reposter one I'll get this
one this one now you have you're paying
like 50 bucks a month [ __ ] stupid ass
apps damn dude I get [ __ ] on NFL
Sunday Ticket I get [ __ ] every day
it's crazy NFL Sunday Ticket to charged
me like 80 a month
I bend over and I [ __ ] take it and
you know and I only want to watch my
shitty ass team lose games right I don't
want to watch every single game
necessarily is there only one price yeah
there's one price you can't like buy
your team but that's what everybody out
there wants we all want to just buy our
shitty ass teams we can watch our team
lose every [ __ ] Sunday that's all I
want nope can't do it you guys are the
subscription like business model dream
yeah we are because you don't ever clean
house on your subscriptions oh dude you
know I saw my Spectrum when I first
signed up for spectrum it was like 50
bucks a month right and I was like all
right whatever I'll pay 50 bucks now I
looked at my statements that [ __ ] is 95
a month it changes uh after a couple
years
three months is 50 bucks oh and then and
then I told this to my buddies and
they're like oh sometimes you just gotta
call and like threaten to cancel they'll
give you a little price okay so a couple
weeks a couple weeks in the NFL season
my Sunday Ticket spits me out constantly
and the stream goes down and I call
their asses up and I'm like I'm trying
to watch my team [ __ ] throw picks and
[ __ ] fumble the boy what is going on
right now it gave me my my month back
best time that's cool that's cool
but like oh you're a Colts fan uh sorry
man I'm trying to watch my team throw
the ball to the other team what the [ __ ]
is going on with my streaming we throw
the best picks is there an incentive at
barbell if someone threatens to leave
no we just let him we try to like have
like the almost non-commercial gym so
like uh if they say okay cool sometimes
you'll hear them go oh it's because I'm
moving out of state like oh it's totally
cool yourself yeah you sure
leaving my gym was like [ __ ] it was
like a divorce it's [ __ ] hard dude
commercial gyms leaving the commercial
gym is [ __ ] hard crazy they're
they'll throw everything oh well you're
going somewhere I was looking for
something because like when I was when I
first moved Vegas I didn't have a home
gym yet so you have to sign up for a 24
hour and then I was like I'm only going
to be here for literally a month and I
know it I'm like can I just buy like
I'll just pay everything right now
through cash and I don't want to have my
credit card because I know the minute
they put that in it's going to be
recurring payment yeah yeah it'll be
half the charge credit card I'm like
dude I'll pay like three months cashes
right now I don't want anything with my
credit card but no you got to do it I'm
like [ __ ] they don't even have a system
for that huh no and then they go okay
just come in just the week before and
you can cancel the week before I go oh
it was what what are you missing you're
missing dead can give you this price now
I'm like no I just really want to get
the [ __ ] out of here their trainings are
so good it's so good you can't get out
and they have to do the script yeah they
have they got to do the script and they
know it works you know what happened
that [ __ ] wasn't happening as I was like
so [ __ ] tired of that [ __ ] I think I
just paid for 24 Hour Fitness for
another year on a year I was like fine
that's how they win
oh yeah yeah you convince yourself that
you're gonna use it and you never
thought all right all right
[Music]
foreign